famed for its cafe culture
Parisians enjoying their Friday evening
were sitting ducks for the terrorists on
a mild November night this is how three
hours of carnage began to unfold these
were the first victims of six
simultaneous attacks a masked gunman
opened fire with an automatic weapon
shooting through windows at a cafe and
restaurant in the same street I heard
some noise when I was at the Bistro
which is where I work I got out I
started running I was looking for where
the sound was coming from I figured out
it was coming from the carry on the
Pitti cam Bush I arrived at the scene
and there were lots of dead bodies on
the ground
lots of dead bodies lots of dead bodies
by now the number of dead had already
reached double figures there were
reports of other shootings
but if there was any doubt Paris was
under siege the sound of a massive
explosion unleashed to a global TV
audience watching France played Germany
left nobody in any doubt a second blast
through the crowd into panic that's
tireless talk infomatics boozy decision
and Frances president Francois Hollande
who'd been at the game to be driven away
to a secure location
the game carried on all the way tonight
minutes as as far as we were aware it
was even though we were getting news
reports we thought it was something
trivial we thought it was a hoax or
something that had gone wrong we didn't
realize spectators flooded onto the open
space of the pitch amidst the specter of
an increasingly terrifying night
seemingly the only safe place they were
prepared to go a look of fear was etched
on some of the most famous faces of
international football as players were
led away unsure of what was happening
there were reports of at least one
suicide bomber at two fast-food cafes
close to the stud de France an attack
designed to Maine fans flocking to a
packed game Warren told how being on the
phone may have saved his life I was
crossing the road and there was an
explosion everything went up in flames
I felt the reverberations I fell down
here's the phone that took the impact
and it saved me
but then as if things couldn't get any
worse it became apparent and major
situation was unfolding at one of
Paris's best-known music venues security
units surrounded the Bataclan theater
[Music]
inside the 1500 seat Hall was a sellout
music lovers had come to watch the
American band Eagles of Death Metal this
mobile phone footage was filmed just
before the attack
[Music]
the gunman stormed the hall shooting in
the air claiming their actions were
revenge for Frances intervention in
Syria the concert had started about half
an hour before we heard firecracker
noises and we turned around and saw two
young people two young people well we
were a bit of far away so two people was
machine guns firing into the crowd so we
all laid on the ground there was panic
screams shots continued to be fired at
the right of the stage a door was opened
and we all rushed there we got stuck
there it was leading to a staircase we
got stuck into a staircase for five to
ten minutes people were trying to force
some doors open that the doors only led
to dressing rooms and green rooms with a
hostage situation now well underway
those inside tried to hide or escape
from the gunman this footage shows the
back of the theatre and the desperate
efforts of some to flee trying to climb
from 1st and 2nd floor windows to avoid
being picked off by the gunman an
injured man made it through a back door
Sid Rebecca's key sparser what's
happening shouts someone
[Music]
[Applause]
others also make it to safety dozens
more would not be so lucky
as it became clear the terrorists had
started killing hostages elite police
units were forced to move quickly one
witness said the gunman was silent and
calm and shot people randomly they would
reload and carry on the attackers in the
hall reportedly three of them then blew
themselves up when the police raid began
[Music]
we were by the bar so he heard
firecrackers or what we thought was
firecrackers we turned around and I saw
two young men and there were older than
25 with Kalashnikovs they told us to lie
down there was one who kept gesturing
for us to get down we all lay down the
whole room lay down I was completely
under other people and they kept
shooting but they would start from time
to time
the survivors left in submission and in
horror at this one venue alone 80 people
lost their lives
[Applause]
Parisians are scarcely able to believe
the multiple atrocities which happened
across their City a state of emergency
has now been announced 1500 military
personnel have been drafted into the
French capital now in lockdown I'm
registering the pain the sadness the
horror and the fear tonight
Paris is once again in mourning the
death toll is very very heavy very very
heavy the places that were hit were
places where Parisians like to go out
where the young people of Paris like to
go on the weekends or in the evenings
they obviously wanted to hit as much of
that liberty of that youth as they could
[Music]
Paris is still hurting from three days
of terror in January which left 17
people dead 12 of them shot at the
offices of the satirical magazine
Charlie Hebdo there were hostages then
as well at a kosher supermarket in the
east of the city
some believe Paris got back to its
casual way of life too easily
others think the people were let down by
the government they failed to anticipate
this attack and will have to understand
why this happened and correct whatever
went wrong and what went wrong went
wrong big time the second item is a very
difficult one and that is the level of
sophistication and expertise of this
attack is really rather scary
the Islamic state has claimed
responsibility for the attacks
blaming France for getting involved in
the Syrian conflict
the French president says his country is
at war it was a deliberate organized and
planned act of war we are working to
establish all the facts it's an
absolutely barbaric act at present there
are 127 dead and many injured with
France on a heightened state of alert
the British government has warned there
could be British nationals amongst the
dead my message to the French people is
simple nous somme solidaire avec vous
new song - source longer we stand with
you United when the attacks began
Parisians were told to stay at home that
hallmark French solidarity may have won
out with people laying flowers and
tributes but there is also disbelief and
a growing sense of vulnerability this
was the scene at the first shooting on
Friday night an ordinary cafe in an
ordinary suburb my cafe with the dead
bodies around and you feel like all my
parents is really
in a strange situation because this
place is not like the top of the world's
not like a show that is a it's not the
sixth on this much local hangout for the
neighborhood because you know with the
Charlie of the shooting
they were like targeting some people
precisely like journalists of course so
you feel the danger but you didn't feel
too endangered now it's like watching
you meet everybody
it's it's really strange to think about
that as they left the star de France on
Friday night evacuated football fans
sang their national anthem the
Marseillaise France was once again
forced to turn fear into defiance
[Applause]
[Music]